time now for pft on yahoo sports mike
florio and peter king oh wait it's not
peter king this week oh yeah christopher
sims in for peter king we're gonna have
a little fun here chris continuing our
discussion as we do every morning on pft
live let's talk for a few minutes shall
we about the los angeles rams they're
embarrassing and humiliating as their
coach sean mcvay called it lost to the
jets on sunday can the rams rebound from
that given that they've got the seahawks
and the cardinals coming up to finish
the season well they can rebound i mean
listen
we both know their defense is still good
right they played good enough to win the
game the other day i mean really hey
golf through an interception there was a
block punt that put their defense in
some tough spots that you know yeah they
gave up some points there with some
short field so i still have faith in
that offensively
mike you and i have discussed this a lot
the big question about the rams going
forward is when the run game and
mcveigh's speed sweeps and runs and the
bootleg don't work can their drop back
pass game and jared goff win them
football games i think that's a really
serious legit question of them and now
they're going to play two teams and the
seahawks and the cardinals who we know
have experienced playing against the
offense and know how to slow down some
of the tricks of the trade there um but
i still think they're going to be a pain
in the butt in the playoffs the rams i
do i'm not giving up on them but that
drop back past part in jared goff has to
improve
cam akers who had developed into their
workhorse tailback he is out for this
weekend's game with an ankle injury that
means daryl henderson or malcolm brown
need to step up chris and without that
presence it's a lot on the plate of
jared goff you've got some strong
opinions i've got some strong opinions
about the contract that he has the label
of franchise quarterback i'm not sure
he's truly earned that he seems to be at
times more of a problem than a than a
benefit to the offense because look he
does the basic things but he doesn't do
the big things right can be the
difference between losing and winning
that that's exactly it you know again
there's a lot of people who can hand the
ball off and throw bootleg passes you
know five yards into the flat you know
and i'm not trying to say jared goff can
only do that there's more he can do i
understand that but when you're being
paid 35 million dollars a year and all
those type of things yeah when mcveigh's
offense doesn't deliver i expect you
to cover up you know the holes or the
mistakes to a degree i'm not asking
realistically for like you to carry the
team every week and do that but yeah
there's a lot of issues with that play
and you know whether you like it or not
i think you kind of hit it the rams are
still in the like managing jared golf
phase which is crazy to say at this
point of his career you know it really
is so we'll see they have typically had
the number of the seattle seahawks in
their matchup ever since mcveigh got
there maybe they keep that streak going
this week big game in the uh nfc west
huge huge game likely will determine the
nfc west championship and uh we'll see
if the rams can indeed turn it around
that's it for this edition of pft on
yahoo sports he's chris sims i'm mike
florio we'll see you next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports